we are quite used to perceiving stars as
something enormous and bright that has
been around for millions and billions of
years
but just imagine that the planets you
live on were located near a
jupiter-sized star whose luminosity was
slightly stronger than that of a dying
amber in a fireplace
this would be a gloomy world with no
future to speak of
it would be doomed to slowly cool off
and eventually find itself
in eternal darkness and cold
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
it may be hard to imagine but our sun
which is relatively small for a star is
heavier than any of 95 percent of stars
in the universe there are also such
things as red dwarves
11 times lighter than our host star
however they're actually not the
lightest objects out there
in the wide range between gas giants and
the smallest stars in the universe
there are some fascinating objects known
as brown dwarves
or dwarf stars
to understand their nature let's have a
look at how a star is born
according to modern scientific theories
stars and brown dwarves originate in the
same star nursery
when nebulae made up of interstellar gas
gradually contract
under the influence of gravitational
forces pressure and temperature inside
the gas increase
the enormous nebulae disintegrate into a
great number of proto-stellar discs
and each of them has a chance of
becoming a fully-fledged star at some
point
its destiny depends on how much matter
the young star will manage to capture
if the mass of a protest star is over 8
percent of that of the sun
thermonuclear reactions are bound to
start in its interior
nuclei of light elements like hydrogen
deuterium
helium or lithium blend together
emitting a great amount of heat
this heats up the interior of the future
star even more
and more and more matter is involved in
these processes
this unleashes a chain reaction which
may persevere for billions of years
until the substances fueling it are
totally
and so an used star is born somewhere
light years away from us
and can probably be observed in the sky
its future depends on its mass
and chemical composition most of its
life cycle will be spent in the main
sequence
phase later the star is likely to turn
into a white dwarf
or alternatively a neutron star or a
black hole
but what if the mass of the forming
protest star is smaller
then the gravitational pressure will not
be enough for the heat produced by the
thermonuclear reaction to increase the
star's temperature to the point
when it is able to sustain the burning
process without additional help from
other sources
nuclear fusion will still take place but
the heat emitted during the process will
not be enough for the star to flare up
instead the object will slowly decay
until the substance is necessary for
thermonuclear reactions are depleted
it's worth mentioning that every kind of
reaction requires a certain temperature
to initiate nuclear fusion
if the star's temperature is lower
nuclei will not be able to get closer
and will be mutually repelled by coulomb
force
the celestial object we're looking at
today is what is known as a brown dwarf
in space
interestingly in spite of their name not
many of them are actually of a brownish
hue
if we could look at them with a naked
eye we would most likely see them
crimson
orange or even black the color depending
on the surface temperature
the hottest brown dwarfs have a
temperature not higher than 3000 degrees
kelvin which corresponds to a faint red
glow
most of them are much colder from 300 to
a couple of thousand degrees kelvin
the peak in their radiation is in the
infrared range which is invisible to the
naked eye
just to compare the coolest star's
surface temperature
is about 4000 degrees kelvin
by radiating heat into its environment a
brown dwarf
gradually depletes its energy and cools
off
thermonuclear reactions in its interior
die down
and the object turns into a ball of
compressed gas
it will cool off gradually and will
resemble a gas giant of impressive
dimensions
after its heat is slowly dissipated a
brown dwarf may in theory cool off to as
little as four
or five degrees kelvin the background
temperature of the universe's relic
radiation
however the temperature of the coolest
space objects of this variety that have
been discovered are about 300 degrees
kelvin
there are several celestial objects that
may yet earn the title of a brown dwarf
one of them is wise
six five 1828-2650 it is in the lyra
constellation and is 47 light years away
from the sun
it is considered the coldest brown dwarf
to have been discovered
although astronomers make scientific
contributions every day
and perhaps we will soon hear of still
cooler objects
a brown dwarf's dimensions are usually
comparable to those of jupiter
while its masses several dozen times
that of jupiter
for example the object coro 3b in the
constellation aquila
about 2 200 light years from the earth
is similar to jupiter in its diameter
but is 22 times heavier
a space object qualifies to be called a
brown dwarf if its mass is approximately
12 and a half to 80 times that of
jupiter
objects heavier than that are red
dwarves those lighter than that
are sub-brown dwarfs super jupiters and
planimos
it goes without saying that such small
and dim celestial bodies are practically
impossible to see with a regular
telescope
the existence of these fascinating
objects was predicted back in the 1960s
although even special infrared detectors
were unable to spot brown dwarves for a
long time
many years passed before the first brown
dwarf had been detected
the great event took place in 1995.
the find was an object dubbed tayder 1 a
rather hot celestial body for its class
it is located in the constellation
taurus approximately 400 light years
away from the sun
its surface temperature reaches 2 700
degrees kelvin
and its mass is 55 times that of jupiter
or 5.2 percent that of the sun
in the years that followed a great
number of other celestial bodies of this
class were discovered
about 100 of them were detected within
as little a radius as 60 light years
from the sun
the total number of brown dwarves in our
galaxy is estimated at 50 to 100 billion
which accounts for about a quarter of
the overall number of stars in the milky
way
the brown dwarf closest to the earth is
just nine light years away from the sun
brown dwarves are rather cool objects by
stellar standards
that is why they may contain complex
compounds like methane
as for the temperature of the coolest
main sequence stars
it is so high that electrons leave their
nuclei
and thus the substance turns into
scorching plasma
even the simplest two atom molecules
like hydrogen
cannot endure this harsh environment
there may be planets orbiting brown
dwarfs
the first satellite of this kind was
detected in 2004
it orbits 2m1207
a comparatively warm brown dwarf in the
constellation centauri
which is 64.6 or 209 light years away
from the earth
this planet is rather large its mass is
four times that of jupiter
can the planets orbiting brown dwarfs be
habitable
it is positive that the chances are slim
but theoretically it is feasible
since brown dwarves are much cooler than
stars their habitable zone is narrower
concentrating closer to the parent dwarf
also it should be noted that the
eccentricity of the satellite planet's
orbit should be low
that is practically ideally spherical in
shape
since a brown dwarf is constantly in the
process of cooling
its habitable zone gradually shifts
closer to it
according to some estimates a rather
heavy and hot dwarf may sustain
conditions
suitable for life on its satellite
planet for as long as 10 billion years
but of course there are admittedly many
other objects in the universe
which are definitely more favorable for
cultivating life
i wonder what you think about chances of
discovering even primitive life forms
close to these harsh celestial bodies
feel free to leave your ideas in the
comments it is always nice to get some
feedback from you
it motivates us to make new videos of
competitive quality to treat you to
if you want a regular tip-off on new
ones hit the bell button
this way you won't miss a new exciting
video to satisfy your inquiring mind
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you